hey there i'm stephen amell and i'm here
with buzzfeed to read my thirst tweets
now they told me that i could read them
before in my head and uh skip the ones
that i thought maybe were inappropriate
that i'm just going for it can we do a
buzzfeed video where stephen mel reads
thirst tweets because there must be
thousands i don't know that there are
thousands and i certainly hope not but
we're about to find out hello god i want
an explanation as to why you put the
ocean inside stephen mello's eyes it's a
problem
thanks i have blue eyes not a little
known fact but certainly not a popular
one that's a genetic deficiency whenever
i see stephen on tv i always whisper
daddy crying emoji heart eyes heart even
before i had a kid there was never a
moment where the use of that word in a
sexual connotation didn't make me feel
wildly uncomfortable thinking about the
one scene in arrow where stephen amell
wears gray sweatpants that would seem to
be a comment about my penis i would lick
stephen mel with lots of grace if you're
going to do it just do it and do it with
enthusiasm stephen mel and alexander
ludwig on a show all about wrestling
called heels god blessed us with a
wrestling kink lol absolutely a lot of
spandex a lot of uh homo eroticism we
used to joke all the time because during
the first season of arrow they made a
gay porn about it and i was remarking to
alexander at dinner the other night that
they don't need to make a gay parody or
gay porno of heels because i think it's
gay enough already been watching arrow
again and i have a blazing hot take
canada's ass is even better than
america's ass thank you for your butt
stephen amell and shout out to you chris
evans steven wearing tight shirts to
comic con is my sexuality for now you're
not that tight i can't do that type of a
shirt makes me too self-conscious shout
out to the lord for putting those thighs
out here jesus christ stephen amell
those legs and that booty what can i say
that's a fundamentally accurate tweet
steven ml is my dream this man is the
daddy i need in my life so perfect that
beard that tight little ass i would love
getting punished by him in his arrow
thank you caleb i feel like you have
found a niche for yourself in the online
world and you keep doing you finds the
remote from click rewinds back to the
time stephen mel didn't own my ass
i don't i've never owned an ass before
if i can do a show where i play a
superhero then do a show for
professional wrestling that means that
two out of three of my dreams in life
have have come true the third being
owning someone's ass thank you steven ml
for being smart ass badass great ass a
lot of stuff about my posterior in this
which is not something that i think
about on a regular basis because i don't
i can't actually see it i tried to get
my ass into the first season of the show
they weren't having it which you know
what seems odd so i think that it
probably has something to do with a
ryder and alexander's contract because
his ass is all over the first season i'm
usually not that into white guys but god
damn if stephen amell were to kill me
i'd die horny
it's dark i would let stephen amell put
it in my butt a few times that's a fine
specimen the ass trend continues here i
can only dream i don't know if it
weren't so morally problematic i would
put it in your butt
i'm gonna say i'm an ass guy stephen
amell more like choked me with your just
for a minute not like you're gonna lose
oxygen to your brain and we're not gonna
be able to bring you back now i'm not
gay but i would let stephen amell ravage
my [ __ ] like a starving tiger i
didn't anticipate this happening but i
by the end of this i find myself
actually like a little bit turned on not
a lot but just a little thank you
buzzfeed if we're gonna have to record
this at the very least i can stroke my
ego if not you know where i'm going you
can check out heels it's debuting all
over the world on stars get the app
watch it on craven canada and based off
of these tweets eventually check it out
on pornhub thank you very much
you